[Musique]
le film que je recommande et robot de
Adil et Larbi et Bilal Falla qui est un
film absolument époustouflant une
coproduction Bellego luxembourgeoise
d'une célébrité locale l'été dernier
s'est rendu en Syrie comme agent
humanitaire
où tu seras fier de
[Musique]
mon fils je t'aime
sur un petit garçon qui malheureusement
se rendent en Syrie pour de mauvaises
raisons et ce que je trouve absolument
fantastique dans ce film c'est que je
crois vraiment que les réalisateurs
voulaient montrer un message tout à fait
éducationnel sans pointer le doigt à qui
que ce soit mais plutôt au contraire
montrer la réalité expliquer le
processus qui malheureusement parfois
conduit à ce type d'aliénation qui peut
toucher vraiment toutes les classes
sociales et tous les âges
[Musique]
des acteurs était d'une justesse
vraiment très très frappante c'est un
film aussi que j'ai beaucoup apprécié
dans le cadre de sa projection en séance
de minuit au Festival de Cannes puisque
les réactions dans la salle du Grand
Théâtre lumière à cette heure tardive
était d'autant plus forte lorsque l'on
vit vraiment la réalité sur le terrain
et je crois que ce message d'éducation
est finalement de pas tourner le dos à
la réalité c'est vrai que c'est toujours
difficile de de faire face à des choses
qui sont absolument épouvantables mais
parfois c'est important aussi de pouvoir
faire passer des messages et comprendre
la réalité ne pas lui tourner le dos
pour pouvoir mieux la confronter
tu vas faire partie de cette vidéo
[Musique]